hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar overcome top titration
challenges i am michelle ashton of lab
herbs and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by laberd's
and brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more please visit
www.meliar.com/mpanel.htm into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational unless offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speakers Rickey
Hartwell senior product manager Leo
scales like off applications lab manager
and Kevin goos senior product manager
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
Ricky Dale and Kevin will now begin
their presentations
okay great Thank You Michelle do any of
these titration challenges sound
familiar as Allison from Villanova
University described the spout detached
from the rest of the burette and
shattered in sabirah it was now open on
the bottom the reagent poured out
spilled everywhere it was a strong base
so we had to neutralize it with acid it
was a big massive reagents and glass
all right here's one does this sound
familiar I was doing an elemental iron
titration that was about two hours of
prep before the final titration for
color change someone walked in the lab
and said my name so I looked up and
missed the endpoints I had to start all
over again with the two hours of prep
that's from Aaron of the Heritage
Research Group
sound familiar Becky from AquaBounty
said at my previous job I had to perform
manual titrations on all incoming
intermediate products for production let
me tell you sitting in one place for
eight hours a day watching miniscule
droplets fall into a container
desperately waiting for the color change
was worse than watching paint dry don't
even get me started about when I'd add
too much too fast and missed the change
altogether
let's talk about titration challenges
and how we can help solve them have you
experienced any of these common
challenges with manual titrations
are you spending a lot of time
performing manual titration
do you need to complete more testing in
the same amount of time for this
titration tip we will discuss how you
can improve accuracy safety and lab
throughput by automating your titrations
sample accuracy is critical to loud
measurements you want to get the correct
results the first time so you do not
have to recheck your procedures review
your results and potentially repeat
testing all over again with manual
titrations you must add small drops of
titrant one at a time into your sample
beaker watch very closely for the
endpoint to be reached by color change
pH or millivolt reading or similar
technique and then record the volume of
titrant use to calculate your resulting
sample concentration and with all these
steps required for manual titration
process there are a lot of opportunities
to make mistakes and introduce errors
into the results accuracy automating
your titrations greatly simplifies this
process as the Thai trader manages all
of these tasks for you
automating titrations can also improve
the results accuracy several ways by
automating titrant additions using
high-resolution microliter volume doses
by using an electrode as the endpoint
indicator that eliminates the need to
interpret or guess when the endpoint has
been reached and by automatically
calculating the concentration results
for you using the same parameters and
procedures every time automating your
titration also allows multiple cycles to
be run on the same sample you can make
sure your testing results are
reproducible with average concentration
and relative standard deviation
calculations performed automatically
plus the ability to exclude any outlier
cycles from these calculated values
safety is also an important factor in
laboratory environments manual Thai
traders require the operator to fill the
burette with titrant and flush the
stopcock
fill the burette exactly to the zero
mark and make sure the meniscus level is
correct each time they need to perform a
titration this process can lead to some
fairly dangerous situations equipment
fails or is mishandled for example some
common issues include if you're Brett
and stander too tall you can spill
hazardous patron on yourself when
filling the burette if you're Brett
system is older or isn't stable your
Brett may fall off the stand and brake
throwing glass shards everywhere and if
your Brett tip or stopcock is loose it
may fail to control
I flow or followed and spell titrant all
over automating your titrations can
greatly improve safety in the lab since
the tie trader offers a fully automated
dispensing system that draws the titrant
from the titrant bottle into the burette
and then dispenses the titrant in small
measured drops into the sample all
without the operator needing to touch
any of the dispensing components our toy
traders off but also offer additional
safety features including a protective
plastic cover around the glass burette
to protect it from damage or breakage
and a programmable maximum defense
volume parameter that prevents the tie
trader from continuing to dispense
patron at the endpoint is not detected
another key factor in labs is sample
throughput most labs are looking for
ways to perform more testing and the
same amount of time or with the same
number of operators performing manual
titrations can be extremely tedious
requiring the operator to stand in one
place watching miniscule droplets drip
into a sample container and diligently
waiting for the color change or other
endpoint indicator to occur before
starting the process all over again for
possibly hours and hours of repeated
sample titrations automating your
titrations allows you to start the
titration and then walk away from the
thai trader to perform other tasks or
tests
while the Thai trader takes care of the
titrant Edition endpoint detection and
results calculation automatically
without any involvement from the
operator once the titration is done the
Thai trader will be notifying the
operator that the results are available
and then other titration can be started
performing titrations is the influence
of the burette accuracy on attaining
good results are you having trouble with
inconsistent titration results are you
using large volumes of titrant to get
clear endpoints are you spending lots of
money on expensive titrant or waste
disposal
for this titration tip we will discuss
how you can improve burette accuracy for
better endpoint detection and titration
results plus achieve dental cost savings
by using less titrant and less sample
leading to less ways to dispose of
manual titrations typically use a
non-certified Class B or Class A Bureau
with South Cobb to add doses of titrant
to the sample the operator uses the
stopcock to start and stop the additions
of titrant into the sample often one
drop at a time until the end point is
reached once the end point is reached
the operator records the total volume of
the titrant added to the sample and uses
this data to calculate the concentration
results for their sample the president
the precision of these additions
especially near the endpoint is
primarily determined by the operators
skill level experience and focus on the
task at hand all too commonly an
operator can allow too much titrant to
flow out of the burette into the sample
and overshoot the end point requiring
them to perform the entire titration all
over again
even highly skilled and experienced
operators can be limited in the
precision of their manual titration
results by the last few drops of titrant
since each drop can vary in volume
another limitation is the burette
graduated volume marks and stated
accuracy typically 0.1 milliliters for
non-certified bureau adds all the way to
0.03 milliliters for Class A bureaus
this is significant since the final
volume of titrant used for the titration
is determined visually by the operator
judging the level of the remaining
titrant in the burette using the
graduated volume marks to compensate for
these limitations often larger volumes
of titrant and sample are use
when using an automated Thai trader the
titration is performing performed using
a high accuracy titrant delivery system
that controls all titrant additions into
the sample and will adjust the dose rate
as it detects the endpoint approaching
once the endpoint is reached the Thai
trader uses the precisely measured
volume of titrant added to the sample to
automatically calculate the
concentration results for the sample the
operators skill level experience and
focus on the task at hand is no longer a
factor in the overall accuracy of the
titration results the possibility of
missing the endpoint is greatly reduced
as a result titrant and sample volumes
can be adjusted to smaller volumes or
used
as we can see in this chart from the
article six things that can go wrong
with your alkalinity titration burette
accuracy is a very important factor for
the uncertainty value of your titration
results this illustrates how using a
better titrant delivery system can
improve uncertainty from plus or minus
two percent down to plus or minus 0.02
percent
look at an example of how using smaller
volumes of titrant and sample can
benefit lab costs
when performing a manual titration to
determine the salt content and prepared
foods using a silver nitrate patron
typically about 20 milliliters titrant
is used for sample titration using an
average cost of a one liter bottle of
silver nitrate titrant we can see that
the cost for tests is about two to four
dollars versus running the same
titration with an automated thai trader
that is optimized to use two millilitres
of titrant per sample by using less
titrant with a more accurate delivery
system and endpoint detection method we
can see that the cost per test has now
decreased to about twenty to 40 cents
plus the additional cost savings of
having less ways to dispose of can
really result in some great savings for
your lab now I'll turn it over to Gail
to discuss our next titration tip
great thanks Ricky on hello to everyone
who has joined us today for this webinar
first I'd like to talk about challenges
around color endpoints - let me ask you
have you ever missed a titration
endpoint is the color change endpoint
hard to differentiate our other
operators choosing different endpoints
and obtaining different results and your
colored or cloudy samples make it hard
to identify the endpoint these are some
common complaints about manual
titrations that I've seen and heard in
my own lab what about you
do you recognize this titrations
titration of acid with base and
phenolphthalein indicator
phenolphthalein actually has a Pinker
color
however if this was the case with this
titration be before the endpoint at the
endpoint or past the endpoint
right this titration would be past the
endpoint especially since
phenolphthalein endpoint is the first
faint pink color that persists longer
than fifteen or thirty seconds
do
cognise this
they methyl orange titration
which color do you think represents the
endpoint the challenge here is choosing
the correct color endpoint if the wrong
endpoints chosen the results won't be
accurate will be a high or a low bias
decisions made on the basis of these
results can be affected
would you choose the same endpoint as
another person doing the titration the
challenge is that different people can
choose different endpoints so when
different people choose different
endpoints they also calculate and report
different results that means they'll be
inconsistency in the results in the
final product depending on who is doing
the titration today
here
titration for sulfur dioxide in white
wine the endpoint is easy to see we go
from almost colorless to a purple blue
color
and for those who prefer a red
River titration for sulfur dioxide in
red wine in this case the endpoint is
not so simple to identify the wine is
red and the endpoint is purple blue it's
so challenging that some lab personnel
will shine a bright light through the
wine during the titration to help try to
make that endpoint easier to see a
challenge determining the endpoint of a
colored or cloudy sample this slows down
our titration increases the uncertainty
of the results and impacts the precision
and the accuracy of those results
to overcome these challenges we'll use
an auto tight trader with pre-programmed
methods
when we automate a titration we can be
confident in overcoming these challenges
we won't overshoot an endpoint it won't
be trouble identifying the endpoint we
won't have different answers for
different operators and we won't be
confused by colored or murky samples
instead our titrations will be
repeatable and reliable no matter what
titration what endpoint who performs the
titration or what sample is titrated
so converting to an automatic titration
is often a simple one-time task
resulting in a saved programmed method
that can be copied shared and used for
all future titrations then with a few
touches on the screen we can run an
automated titration from the saved
method once we start the titration we
can walk away and perform other
activities in the lab or at our desk
maybe even grab a cup of coffee
a simple option for automating a manual
titration is to use a pre-programmed
method it's already available in the
Thai trader
these methods are available in
application notes on our website or by
contacting your local representative
these application notes contain a wealth
of information to help you be successful
with your titrations including the
recommended equipment and solutions the
programmed method sample preparation
information performance data and tips
and tricks for customizing your method
and getting the most from your tight
reader
in the field of water there are some
examples of titrations that are easy to
convert from manual to automatic
titrations alkalinity as total
alkalinity or M&P alkalinity calcium
hardness total hardness chloride and
Winkler do
there are some examples of food and
beverage titrations that are simple to
automate
sulfites and wine acidity of orange
juice and other beverages salt and
prepared food and sodium and canned
vegetables
and here are some examples of chemical
petrochemical titrations it can be
automated including acid number or ta n
base number or TB n mercaptans and
chlorides
right
so have you ever noticed that an old
container of titrant gives different
results than when it was new
does your titrant change color over time
have you noticed precipitation in your
titrant bottle or burette does your
titrant evaporate and lose volume over
time if any of these changes happen it
means that the titrant
concentration is no longer the same as
the value printed on the bottle or the
certificate of analysis any titrations
that we do perform with this compromised
patron will not give us accurate results
let's talk about titrant sand some
challenges we face regarding the
integrity of our titrant true or false
titrant concentration printed on the
bottle or the certificate of analysis is
accurate throughout the youth life of
the titrant
well the answer is depending on the
titrant and the storage conditions that
may be false here on the right is an
example of how the concentration of a
potassium hydroxide titrant in
isopropanol changed over five
non-consecutive days of testing in my
lab this is the titrant used for acid
number titrations in oil
by the last day of testing the actual
concentration of the titrant in the
burette had changed by about 18% if I
had assumed that the concentration of
the titrant
was still 0.1 normal as stated on the
bottle and on the certificate of
analysis my results would be off by 18%
that wouldn't be good
over time standard titrant solutions age
and can change concentration due to
variety of factors it can affect the
titrant integrity including air exchange
oxygen and carbon dioxide in the air can
interact with our titrant
evaporation precipitation of a component
in our Titan exposure to light or just
contamination
this is particularly true for certain
Titans
examples
base or alkaline titrant iodine titrant
silver nitrate thiosulfate and arsenide
titrant
and non-aqueous hydrants
the titan ages a certified concentration
may no longer be accurate when the
titrant concentration is not accurate
our results won't be accurate
so when increasing the accuracy of a
titration is important look at
standardizing the patron and take steps
to preserve the patron integrity
for best accuracy periodically determine
the exact concentration by standardizing
the patron note it is common to
standardize on a daily or weekly basis
but other standardization frequencies
may be suitable
standardising is as simple as titrating
a measured volume or weight of a known
standard the true titrant concentration
is then calculated and used for future
sample calculations to improve the
accuracy and the confidence in our
results
the option to standardize is available
in each programmed method when activated
the home screen of that method will then
show the choice to standardize whenever
desired
when standardizing we can run one
standard titration or we can run
replicates up to five times to increase
the confidence of our results
hi trader will then calculate true Titan
concentration and the rsd of the
replicants so that we don't have to
this true Titan concentration will
automatically be saved and used for
subsequent titrations with that method
in this way we are achieving better
accuracy with our sample titration
results
customers may prefer not to standardize
their titrant instead these customers
can choose to purchase and use certified
standardized titrant solutions
in this case users can edit the patron
section of the method and enter a
certified concentration and a titrant ID
entering the lot number in the patrons
ID is a good way to track our titrant
data
in either case whether standardizing arm
not take steps to preserve the integrity
of your titrant
use the recommended titrant bottles caps
and tubing which are designed to
minimize evaporation and prevent
particles from getting into the patrons
protect your light-sensitive titrant use
a brown or opaque bottle to hold your
Titans
titrant such as sodium hydroxide titrant
for certain titrations can't be
protected protected from the carbon
dioxide in the air place a carbon
dioxide sorban in the describe a tube on
the titrant cap air intake
the tinted burette cover automatically
screens out UV light to protect the
patrons in the burette
and choosing opaque tubing will also
protect your titrant from the effects of
UV light by taking these steps we can
extend the youth life of our titrant
minimizing the frequency of
standardization and increasing the
accuracy of our results
you
now let's look at some tips to improve
our titrations
with a few simple modifications we can
take steps to make our titrations
shorter to do more titrations in less
time waste less sample save on expensive
titrant and generate less waste
we can customize our method to titrate
faster and run more samples when speed
and sample throughput are important
there are different options for
maximising the titration
stirring faster will speed the titration
as long as there's no splashing and no
strong vortex created in the sample I
found in my lab that going from a medium
to a fast stir can make a titration go
35% faster that means that if I used to
spend an hour Thai treating a batch of
samples now it will just take me 40
minutes or I could run a third more
sample in that hour
option is to speed up a titration by
choosing a different titration process
control parameter for example if the
control is set to routine we can try
changing too quick to speed up the
titration I've found in my lab that
going from a routine to quick process
control can make a titration go about 14
or 15 percent faster for example that
shaves about 35 seconds off 4 minute
titration
another option is to make use of the pre
dos parameter
if our titration typically takes a known
amount of titrant we can program a pre
dose into the method
when we do that
hi trader will quickly dose the amount
of titrant right at the start and bring
us close to the end point right away for
example if a titration typically takes
about five mils we might choose a three
and a half or a 4 mil pre dose pay
trader will add the pre dose quickly and
then only must titrate for the end point
in the last mill or so I've found in my
lab that adding a pre dose can shave
minutes off a titration time and I can
get a lot more done in a shorter amount
of time
that I'll discuss is this one this
option is the option to titrate left
sample for example if the 50 mil sample
takes 10 mils of titrant we can try
using 10 mils of sample which will only
take 2 mils of Titan when using an auto
tight trader 2 mils can be added in
0.001 mil increments and that allows
plenty of precision even though only a
small amount of titrant is used I don't
need to dispense large volume of titrant
in order to obtain precise and accurate
results
reducing the amount of sample titrated
means a shorter titration and brings the
benefit that last sample is required and
less of your titrant is required
you
will generate less waste per sample well
thanks for listening in on these
titration tips I hope you found them
helpful now I'm going to hand you over
to Kevin goos our senior product manager
who will provide some great tips for
choosing your electrode calibrating and
caring for your electrode for the very
best performance Kevin take it away
thank you for that intro to moving on in
in choosing the right electrode we'll
look at how you can achieve accurate
results what produces the fastest
response
how will you ensure repeatability and is
it possible to mitigate temperature
effects
and the next few slides I'll go through
some best practices to help you get the
best possible tie trader results
when faster titrations are sought after
with improved precision and accuracy you
must know that your electrodes need to
be in peak condition to provide the
results that you're looking for
an accurate fast and repeatable pH
electrode leads to fast and accurate pH
titrations so choosing the right one is
important for example ASTM has written
standards for acid number and base
number titrations that recommend a
specific type of pH electrode be used in
conjunction with the test procedures to
verify the specified electrode
performance the pH electrodes that we
recommend in our non aqueous pH
titration application notes for acid
number and base number meet the
performance specifications of these ASTM
standards numerous app notes as shown on
the slide
have been written by thermal scientific
that specify which selected electrodes
would be most suitable for an automated
titration the use of the right automatic
temperature compensation probe coupled
with one of the most thermally stable
raus electrodes will get you to the
results that you're looking for please
note for non aqueous samples our shore
flow electrode with a spring-loaded
flushable open angular Junction can
easily be utilized to replace the outer
fill solution with a non aqueous fill
solution to avoid junction potential
bias now let's move on to accuracy
in most cases it is recommended that you
calibrate your pH electrode once a day
when titrating acid based samples
if in doubt about the stability of the
calibration over the course of the day
read a pH buffer standard in the measure
mode that is close to the endpoint pH
that you're looking at
if the buffer reads close to the
accepted value at the measured
temperature your calibration is still
good typically we're looking to be
within plus or minus 0.05 pH units of
the standard in some cases for example
if the titration technique is an
equivalence point rather than a preset
endpoint and the measurement units
chosen are millivolt units rather than
pH units calibration is not necessary
for accurate titration results however
calibration still gives valuable
information about the performance of the
electrode and can indicate the need for
maintenance or replacement
let's look at some added tips
it is always best to calibrate with at
least two buffers that will bracket your
end measurement
not to have a pH difference of these two
buffers more than three pH units to help
improve accuracy while some users may
wish to do a multi-point calibration
it is always recommended that a
multi-point calibration be done in a
sequential point-to-point method and to
not use a linear regression method
example a common practice is to
calibrate with a four and seven buffer
and verify against the six point eight
six buffer for our electrodes when it
comes to measuring slope as a result of
the calibration we typically look to
have a slope within 95 to 102 percent
and an offset I know more than fifty
nine millivolts so we can look at our
automatic buffer recognition now let's
look at caring for your electrodes
good electrodes require some routine
care just like a car
flush and refill the filling solution
regularly weekly or bi-weekly is usually
effective
store the electrode in a recommended
storage solution and change the storage
solution bi-weekly or storing it
long-term place the electrode into the
protective cap that originally came with
your electrode with some additional
amount of storage solution
so for some added cleaning tips
depending on the type of sample analyzed
periodic cleaning may improve the
performance of the electrode
type of cleaning solution used will be
influenced by the samples being analyzed
grease and oily samples disinfection
requirements and proteins are all
examples of required specific solutions
for proper cleaning please follow the
recommendations in your application
notes or the pH electrode user guide
that accompanies each electrode
those are the tips that are we covered
for caring for your electrode and
getting the best accuracy for your
titrate ER needs come back to you Ricky
great thank you Kevin
last tip let's discuss challenges with
performing titrations and properly
recording titration data correctly
calculating the sample concentration
from the endpoint volume and maintaining
detailed records for long-term storage
and testing verification are you
spending a lot of time manually logging
your titration data do you want to
easily calculate sample results from
your titrations do you need to maintain
better long-term data storage records
for this titration tip we will discuss
how you can simplify data recording
calculations and improve long-term
storage of your data record
to simplify data collection we would
never forget to record an endpoint
volume instead of manually recording the
endpoint volume after performing a
titration use an automated Thai trader
that automatically records the endpoint
volume in addition to the individual
points that compromise the titration
the tabular data can be viewed on the
tight raters computer software or in
Excel plus automated Thai traders allow
you to view the real-time live graph of
titration data on their displays
allowing for immediate verification of
titration progress and results accuracy
another way to simplify data collection
we would always use the crack formula to
calculate titration results correctly
instead of manually calculating the
sample concentration from the titration
results use an automated thai trader
that automatically calculates the sample
concentration from the entered
parameters plus on the automated thai
trader electrode titrant and titration
setup parameters can be saved as a
method so the exact same settings are
used for each titration these methods
can be transferred between Thai traders
for consistent procedures to be used on
multiple tight traders or multiple labs
this way you can save time with repeated
titrations without by running the exact
same parameters each time without having
to re-enter information our next way to
simplify data collection we would always
ensure the data is properly saved for
long term data retention instead of
manually logging the titration results
in a notebook or scrap of handy paper an
automated Thai trader will automatically
save the titration results in the data
log with time and date stamps plus for
long term data retention the automated
Thai trader allows you to print data to
a compact printer or transfer data files
using the Thai traders computer software
or USB flash drive with your choice of
PDF report files or comma separated or
CSV files for use in Excel so now you
can use your preferred way to retrieve
critical data for tracking requirements
thank you for listening to our tips for
improving your titrations I hope you
have discovered some new ideas to help
with your individual testing
let us help solve your titration
problems with thermo scientific Orion
star T 900 series automated laboratory
toy traders
we offer three dedicated models for
frequent routine titrations of similar
samples the Orion star T 9:10 pH ty
trader
the Orion star T 920 redox titrate and
the Orion star T 9:30 ion ty trader
plus we offer one multi-purpose
all-in-one model for occasional
titrations varied samples the Orion star
T 940 all-in-one tie trader for more
information on any of these instruments
please visit thermo Fisher comm flash
tie trader thank you again for your time
and attention
Thank You Ricky Gail and Kevin for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started
our first question is can you address
titrations a very viscous solutions
hi this is Gail I'll take that question
that's a good question
so discus samples can present challenge
during titrations the success of the
titration will depend on the ability to
stir the sample effectively if we can't
get a good complete stir then the
reaction will be slow and the electrode
response will be slow so if that's the
case we want to consider diluting the
sample before we start the titration if
the sample is aqueous we can look at
diluting the sample with reagent grade
water if the sample is non aqueous we
can look at diluting it with a titration
solvent that's appropriate to dissolve
the sample in either case we may want to
consider then running a blank on
whatever we've titrated to sample with
thank you
thanks Kel looks like we may have
another one for you here says Gail you
mentioned using a certified titrant in
standardizing the titrant which do you
do in your lap yeah well in my lab I've
used both approaches using a certified
titrant
and standardizing my titrant so for
example when titrating an alkaline
sample with a certified acid titrant I
found that that concentration stays
quite stable over time and so therefore
I don't feel that I need to standardize
it with any frequency on the other hand
when titrating an acid number sample in
oils the titrant is potassium hydroxide
in isopropyl alcohol and that's a
volatile titrant and I found that that
concentration does change noticeably
with time so I found that it makes sense
for me to standardize the titrant on a
regular basis so that it can keep my
titrations accurate as that
concentration changes over time
thank you okay next question can I use
my existing electrodes from other Orion
meter yes Kevin I'll take that too
of course as long as the performance of
the electro that you're using is
compatible with the sample that you're
trying to assess absolutely yeah and as
long as the connections are compatible
with the tie trader itself so
maintaining a healthy electrode that you
know is performing well is certainly
encouraged it will give you more
confidence in your automatic titration
thank you all right next question this
is a two-part question so I'll just
start with the first part is how can we
standardize the tie trader and the
second part is is the tie trader
approved from pharmacopoeia
okay so I'll take the first part of that
our automated Thai trader has a function
built-in for Standardization so it just
requires a couple parameters B programs
and the Thai trader will automate the
standardization just like it automates
the sample titration so again removing
all of the detailed technical flow and
automating it for you in terms of
approved for pharmacopoeia you know
typically is the process or the method
that's approved and not necessarily the
piece of equipment we have a really
great team of technical support
specialists here that can help you with
your individual applications so what we
can do is reach out to you after this
webinar and find a little bit more
information about exactly what your
application is and what you're trying to
measure and help find out if our Thai
trader would be a good fit for your your
samples
thank you is there a printer option
available
yes there is we have a compact printer
available that connects directly with
the tie trader
it requires no setup and integrates and
the tie traitor automatically recognizes
it that's our star a - 106 printer and
if you want more information it's also
available on thermo Fisher comm flashed
a trader
great thank you okay next question we
have the Model T nine one zero two
how can it be standardized
okay it's a pretty simple process again
to standardize when you're under the
titrant settings the default setting is
manual entry of your titrant
concentration you just want to select
standardization and then go through the
parameter prompt which it'll walk you
through everything you need to enter in
order to standardize your tie trim and
if you have any additional questions if
you need more detail again reach out to
us and we'll be able to help you our
contact information is on thermo Fisher
comm / trade trader
great thank you okay you mentioned
saving money on silver nitrate titrant
we test for salt in food titration
do you have a kit for that we do have
the kit for that we pair our Orion star
T 930 ion tie trader with a silver
billet electrode and give that to you at
a bundled discount we also have an
application note and a pre program
method available for that particular
application the salted food so again all
that information is available on our
website and we also have local support
teams who can give you more information
so reach out to us and and we'll provide
that information to you
okay great it looks like we have one
more question here I've done a number of
titrations in the past and for some
reason the end point seems to have
slowed down and now takes longer what
could be causing that
hi it is probably the case that the
electrode could benefit from some
maintenance at this point if the
electrode becomes dirty or hasn't been
maintained if the response can get
slower and this will slow down the
titrate er so if that's the case we want
to take some routine precautions which
is possibly drain and refill the
electrode with new storage excuse me
filling solution we probably want to
look at how we're storing the electrode
to make sure that that solution is clean
and that we're storing it in the best
possible manner and it's possible also
that the electrode would need to be
cleaned and those instructions are
generally found in the electrode user
manual on how to clean and store your
electrode
if they need to refresh the quality
surface of the bulb that would also be
done so you know making sure that
overall it's either it's slowing down
because of the responsibility electrodes
respond slowing down because of the
aging of the bowl which could be
reconditioned or as gala saying it could
be possibly the the junction is being
clogged and needs to be cleansed it will
also help to speed up the response of
the electrode
okay
thank you again Ricky Gil and Kevin for
your time today and your important
insights we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions any questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand laboratory via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye